في غضون ذلك اعلن حاكم شبه جزيره القرن
الموالي لروسيا ان دفاعات الجويه اسقطت
الليله الماضيه طائرات اوكرانيه مسيره فوق
شبه جزيره القرم ماده الى اصابه شخص بجروح
والتضرر مباني سكنيه وبثت وسائل اعلان
الروسيه عبر منصات التواصل مقطع فيديو
للاضرار التي لحقت بالمباني السكنيه وصورا
لحطام وبقايا الطائرات المسيره الاوكرانيه
وابدا معك حسان مسعود عن المواقف الرسميه
المتعلقه بالبيانات العسكريه حسب الروايه
الاوكرانيه لمجريات وتطورات الاوضاع على
الارض
نبدا من الخبر الذي تحدثتم عنها ازدهار
وهو القصف الذي جرى في القرم عبر مسيرات
وفقه
الشهود عيان قاموا بتصوير هذه المقاطع
خلال الليله الماضيه انتشرت مقاطع عن قصف
بطائرات مسيره وعن اصوات تحريق هذه الطير
الطائرات البيان الرسمي الذي صدر عن وزاره
الدفاع تحدث عن انفجارات لم يشر الى
طبيعتها
جرت
لصواريخ من طراز كالوبر كانت تنقل عبر
السكك الحديديه في شبه جزيره القرم هذه
كانت المره الاولى التي تشير اليها بشكل
واضح وزاره الدفاع
لانفجارات في القرم ولكنها في ذات الوقت
تحدثت عن ان هذه الانفجارات غامضه وفق
تعبيرها هذه الروايه الاوكرانيه لما حدث
في القرن خلال الليله الماضيه ولكن في ذات
الوقت فان حديث هيئه الاركان اليوم
تحدث عن صد القوات الاوكرانيه لمئه 120
هجوما على الجبهات المختلفه على مستوى
الجبهات في شرق البلاد تحديدا في بخموت
التي تشهد قتالا متواصلا تحدثت عن صدها
لاربع محاولات تقدم من اربع اتجاهات
مختلفه باتجاه بخموت لا سيما من الجهه
الشماليه والجنوبيه الغربيه لمنطقه بخموت
بالاضافه الى صددها لهجمات في كل من جنوب
المنطقه التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه دونتسك او مارينكا
كذلك في المنطقه الجنوبيه او حتى عند
منطقه لمن شمال مقاطعه دوناتك وكذلك عند
محور كوبيانس كشرق مقاطعه هذه التطورات
تاتي ايضا في ظل حديث هيئه الاركان عن 21
هجوما
بالصواريخ خلال اليوم الماضي بالاضافه الى
قصف مدفعي طال اكثر من 60 بلده على مستوى
الجبهات المختلفه في المنطقه الشرقيه كما
في مقاطعتي
وخرسون هذه هي التطورات الميدانيه التي
تاتي ايضا في ظل وعود اوروبيه غربيه
وامريكيه بتقديم المزيد من الدعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا في ما جرى في القرن هنالك روايه
روسيه رانيا نستعرضها عن طبيعه اسقاط
المسيرات والاضرار ايضا التي حدثت جراء
ذلك
نعم محمد ما مؤكد حتى هذه اللحظه وفقا
للتصريحات الرسميه التي صدرت عن السلطات
المحليه المواليه لروسيا في شبه جزيره
جزيره القرم وهي ان بالفعل منطقه جاكوار
الواقعه في شمال شبه الجزيره كانت قد
تعرضت لهجوم بالمسيرات حتى هذه اللحظه لا
معطيات عن عدد المسيرات ولكن هناك تاكيد
ايضا من قبل رئيس هذه الجمهوريه على ان
انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه في المنطقه
تمكنت من اسقاط هذه المسيرات ووفقا
لتصريحات مستشار الرئيس فانها كانت تريد
استهداف محطه القطارات في جون كوي المباني
التابعه لهذه المحطه ولكن
حاليا هذه المحطه تعمل وفقا لي ما يعني
عملها طبيعي لا لا توجد اي اضرار قد طالت
هذه المحطه وان الاضرار طالت فقط مبنى
سكني بالاضافه الى متجر وذلك جراء اسقاط
احدى المسيرات
[تصفيق]
اكثر من 100 قذيفه بالتزاول مع ذلك ايضا
اعلن السلطات المواليه لروسيا في كرسون عن
استمرار القوات الاوكرانيه باستهداف
المناطق والاحياء السكنيه في الضفه اليسرى
من نهر الحديث يدور عن استهداف تسعه مناطق
سكنيه بنحو اربعين قذيفه فضلا خلال الليل
الماضيه بالاضافه الى استهداف تسع مناطق
اخرى خلال اليوم الماضي هذا من جهه من جهه
اخرى ايضا هناك يعني تطورات مستمره في
مدينه باخ مثل التي تحاول قوات فاجنر
السيطره عليها الحديث يدور عن تقدم للقوات
المسلحه الروسيه من الشمال والشمال الغربي
القوات الروسيه تدفع بالقوات الاوكرانيه
وقدرهم تحصيناتها لاسيما في منطقه اريخ
وبالاضافه الى تقدم في المناطق الجنوبيه
ومحاوله السيطره على الطريق السريع من باق
مثلي مدينه قسطنطينه
حسن مسعود شكرا جزيلا لكما